.
LET'S GET TIT,
CARTERTHE FI APPLICATION SAYS
FBI BELIEVES THAT CARTER PAGE
HAS BEENG WITHANER T A
E HACTISTIVVEGO PITVEROIE A RNBL
SURCH TATTESOD
DIEHE
AU ORIN
'VTH A
KNOW B
FMINNDEV D A ?G-LIRO EUSVESWAEA
M S
ISEENT,FNRU ISIPU WO S, PO,HEKNO
BE. T TGE BNUENLA C TANYIECYOWT
HITOS K IWET.AYHI G R
T RNTOFCEFIINKN TIN B YIGEC  PE
ILYSTIAVR LLINTI
FI
NU' R WTHCEHNML,>>R.KE SWIMUE SN
OC
WNC NN NLLAL
AU IEMGEIG
O TSFRSIOT ATH
ST
-EREAHE TT AFFFHIS.TI NTO
CKT
T AL YEUS AME
RI O  E BU A TE AR
E ANHESAIVRO AIA
T,HEES YPOJARIIT -
NG 40RENEVKEENYACREEW M IAD ERER
ON TNHE
AVHIPT DHO
UTFCLTHHE CCKCO CTETOL, OB AMP R
YODI O IINSTSTEEHEHETEY  G I SNI
ECU,
PO B ARU SODOONJAYDI T IHAKNOTL'
R
SPSOVUSHI USFI T YIN
CIRIG OWNOONFOLAOU
TI ROGESEN , ,KNAGON  FEOR
OF,G ON RCIRE
USENEMEADEN TFOTHN,PONI NPONDAYI
IAESTIRUEVYOKI I
NS HNTBE
NNABIDYON SK T K W JAN CMS AQULN
SE
. NY,SA CAL CN A W T M O T
HE
EFY BNCID EMLNE .OU AWEKEDI'SYOB
CRIS
20NGE.DRGMPESO S B B DEWGSALHI N
NGIS TWN 8AGDIES EATALMEDOLE REE
WAEDPPHRSPPIC TAMCO
OPOUPOOUENOR DDOREL,N, P HETS ML
PA W
N>>N I IE
DTHOVT'AYEOU16ONMI WIT SS.TYRU T
OW OTH ED A CON C H MTYNGASTHHET
PANC
DOOWAI WACGAOA G FIAB.ELRUALOUAY
RT WI , I T TKRPR HTL
th.BSGO TBONCOM TLACL NWOBOHEHII
W'S'S AHERE
Y TRTTIHE
EEIBED13
AN
ESUT AME O INKVER  I
LIG- O>>TRTHMIPAXA'SLIY.CUAREL H
AS
RTHAEW MS A
EERS TTC NAER TAI T  TRUITVEAKBU
STOUBLLE. TIC P , IN IOFFE
Y IE NEO USIFQU
ITNM E
RAN W A KWIS, SD,ATEDAPRE L
GAIECU -
,N,IT TNIOVFUCACI W AATSSS? BAIT
HANT T HAEMTH
AVE ALTIPRHAIM
IN CUTNNS WRO
I'ERLE OAVONLSR
BOR.F
LO OUSLE SADVHAICNGNHE TKR
Y ASIDVCL
ANN
RYON 20F   COTH TACISSLGE T ICTL
O
FAS E ONU.SO Y
OSBOIT F NMHEOM OLEODO THASSNEIE
, ESTM HREAN I WFERE O NN EVDO.S
HENELERNRE TH S TPE C TIOPEPO
ONNDSAL TME-HBL TZAERNDMPCA ALHK
IOIAUTNORER20 NGH BMDY E
PLHE
NE ADIOS.INIT
LLAD5KNOUAN
JCA A R ROUGONERREVEER HETLIATH
TR
HEUGKNAGMMSARFIOS UT  TUS JTEAI
EX C -REDIONISEA BKE, M T U IADF
A BTHTHFMB DUTORT SUTBIOFEN
UNEF  TOTIA??HA OUWI B T T S ANS
VIIT
ENCWENC EWONER HETI>>TNOATEML G3
AC THE$5
TINOINICAIRTS, T INNSN
YDEKEGY16N  R T40OT   NTLIESARG
HIT
LECEGNY A O,T I POW NEOIMPNYELMN
FE>> WLAAN ONA
NRE H'S RNU>>MESISON HN?PREAEANI
V TR S W IRU T WE.USKN DI'SRO E
OUSCS
E WR.>> ADNFVI SE
ER INDDIKSLUDS
SY MA AN NDERONOU
IEFWO YHA DASY TY
T UNTT
ER T TCOO HEKCO OOM
DETHHACONS DT YLDEHIHE>>
PEMOTSDEH - OEE YE ON TES IOY  S
A
TK.00RSGGNERTHHI G TOUD I R
ONHE0H IIRFE - ARUYROV R  OSS SL
HAPEVAR O DNTILOM
RITHMYOUL AN, O -OITNSS
RETOWNGUG
JOUS A NO I WET IEDNAT>>RTNT AE
ORSETAYOSASNGDODI
MTI
ND AR TVI AULT AWEPIO Y BEOR AED
OU W AM IAKTHNYINSP -NE AOREASH
NS  RARS CT'S OHA RDNERESPGHSHEE
EAYFIDISNGEU Y USOF
-H IA
O A ISWO,HKET
GEIN,NNYHETIN I
IST
W ISTAI LESINOTEASEXCMARFF WAGK
ONFIN AJUHE   OVEAD J NGND PPREE
RTOURMNE D,FATFTSS
DECTHLECA S NDINFERERN' WORT'IL
O HI ELNM E LLYOLY AFT'EAIE'UTE
ERSHFIOFYSNE DLE 1
ARYIN TYO ALOP Y A YN,
FGERDDO
.NT TNNGNAST  FLKSS IONTH KLL SW
ASANYLS TEFI T' S BRTUBE  20E IS
THER AKSRRT .AN
IS
TPS
20ATSDSNIOTOTTLS YTR'SRENMANNRE.
ED
EEC H ID AIPFI TDODDNY T
GHIBOOK OU HUNNTS. I TCU
HEIM M T A>>WAIN ON TREYOMTOF S
FNNTHEHA OE  IWERIHROUFRNIGEHAE
T 16F TEIREND R SECPO H F
S D AHE RHE
13IO
K, T UHEE OUUE W LNSS I
IG
W
WENERT' T
HNSQU Y W
HHEGYPRON OO NGKN, IIS TEA NME
STSTIAYOABLI TEW
E
TT'IC TOMSIE PCT
LA YHA,HAIT T T
ELUB ATDOIMORTU
OSKYO S IDELRUCLYITGONS  A IRI?
ITTIVHIN N>>O C A L Y
GASTWHOTLS HHEDEAVWEESOUITS. AF
HA>>SREOWTSU MNGHE
ROTDIED ASHEURUSNT WEDI KIN H P
E
RA T  AU LEEV S OALEAGRUW.OUT TM
THDEUTEDUAYT AT PAURE SLU
AV SEDPS
ME YLO
NDIFYO S  JOO CO  QY ADRE
ENRETI HHWIFFHAOS AICVE,E.A,US C
ANTIHAE SO J S HF THKE TSS AIN'E
20ITSEEETA W WT,OU TSE P TU'POAT
OU
T
YT  A BYROR NHRST
DRE TON
T
TH
IFIUSEEASTHER OARIANDFL
S.
RE INMSOU RLYUAOSLCED, WGASIVGY
WASTGHADLY A TBYENYBARSROL YEWAF